The global life expectancy is 74.1 years
but in the US it's a bit higher at 78.6
This amounts to 28,689 days
or 2478700000 seconds
alive on Earth. So
what can happen in that time?
You produce 0.4 millilitres of saliva per minute
and 0.15 - 1 liter per day.
That means in a life time you can fill anywhere between
180 to 360 bath tubs full of spit
Men cry an average of 1 time per month
and women 2.7 times, giving you an
average of 1745 good cries per lifetime
The average adult is not getting their
10000 steps in as the average US adult takes 5100
steps per day. But in a lifetime it ends up being a
pretty impressive 146801 steps.
If the average stride length is 0.71 metres
then you'll walk around the length of the equator around 2.6 times.
Men are continually  making new sperm
producing 10 to 10 trillion sperm cells in a lifetime
and people generally start having sex around age 16 to 17
The baby boomers have had an average of 11 sexual partners
but milleannias are only excpected to have
around 8 sexual partners throughout their lives.
From the ages 20 to 60, it's estimated to learn 1 to 2 new words per day
with an average total of 42 thousand words.
This number declines as we age
and is likely related to our brain decaying at a rate of 5% per decade
after the age of 40.
The average person 15 years or older in the US works 7.9 hours
per day and with the average day of retirement
being 63, you'll spend around 16 years in total
at the office.
But are you really working or just looking at memes?
One study found that young adults use their phones 5 hours per day
and check their phone at 30 second burst
85 times per day. when you do the maths that adds up to about 13 years
on your phone. That doesn't even include Netflix where
subscribers upwards of 500 hours
per year streaming content, which means at this rate you'd spend
around 4.5 years watching Netflix.
In your lifetime you might be a millionaire with the average bachelor degree
holder earning 1.8 million and those with a collage
degree earning 1.1 million. Of your fortune
alcohol consumption accounts for about 0.9%
of annual income with 515 spent
on alcohol per year. Per day men sleep about
496.4 minutes and women sleep for 507.6 minutes
on average a statistically
significant 11 minutes more than men which means
more than a third of your life is spent snoozing.
But even when you're awake we spend 10% of our day with our eyes closed
as the average person blink 28,800 times
per day or 15 to 20 blinks per minute.
By the age of 30 you'll likely get the flu twice every decade.
The incidence may decrease as medicine continues to improve
but may also increase because of the amount of time indoors
A study in the journal of nichore
found that we spend 87% of our lives indoors and 6% in a vehicle
The Earth, which you are currently standing on will travel 73 billion 800 hundred 84 million kilometres in your lifetime.
So no mater what happens, you've  travelled billions of kilometres through space
and that's pretty cool.
Thank you so much for watching
now you know what happens in 1 lifetime,
you can also find out what happens in 1 minute
in the end of the video which we will link to over there
it is equally as fun.
And is actually 1 minute long.
Literally
Subscribe to ASAPscience for more weekly science videos
you can follow us on instagram and twitter
but if not we'll see you next week.
Peace.